support the crazies if you want to build
a powerful movement if you want
customers loving what you're doing and
spreading the word for you then you need
to support the crazies the loners the
outcasts of people who believe the same
thing that you do who love what you're
all about but I have nowhere else to go
you're giving them a home you're giving
them encouragement and confidence
because they're the strange ones you're
creating a home for the crazies you
might be thinking Evan you've lost it
you're off you're off your rocker here's
what I mean okay I've got a buddy of
mine he's got a training company so he
sells training in two companies people
who want to get better at learning
computers or soft skills or whatever it
is within any organization you're going
to have people who love training who are
all about training they're all these are
you people in the HR department and you
can have the people as a training really
I got to do more training just let me do
my work let me do my job right that's
going to be most people they don't want
to sit through more training so they're
always beating down on the people who
are saying you need training you need
training the people who love training in
a company our tiny percentage their
little tiny percentage and they're
constantly facing negative feedback and
resistance from everybody else around
them and it may cause them the question
themselves you want to create that home
for people who love training make them
feel like they're not alone make them
feel like they belong to something
here's a more personal example I believe
in entrepreneurs I want to see you be
successful people in your circle right
now may say you're crazy what are you
doing go get a job be realistic and if
you surround yourself with those people
and you keep hearing their message over
and over and over and over again it's
really hard to stay motivated it's
really hard to keep going if somebody
keeps telling you this is a stupid idea
how long can you keep going and not
seeing progress in and momentum how long
until you give up and quit
most entrepreneurs quit jizz too soon
you need to surround yourself with
people who believe in you and that's why
people come and watch these videos
that's why you're here watching that's
why people come and visit my website
because I've helped create a home a
community for entrepreneurs to let you
know that you're not alone that what
you're doing is important that you need
to keep doing this we need to stay
strong and not listen to those people
you're the crazy one and you should be
proud of that and so is the home for
crazy people crazy entrepreneurs who
dare to think just different who want to
change the world that's what this is all
about your company should do the same
thing you want to support the crazy
people who are out there who want to be
different who want to change your status
quo within your industry whatever you're
selling whatever you're selling there's
a certain portion of the population who
will love what you're all about who will
love trying something new who will love
taking on this new challenge working
with your business they'll love it I
most of the other people they won't care
you need those crazy people to feel like
they have a home like they can help
support you help spread your message
because those are the guys who are going
to convince everybody else when they
feel empowered and confident and on the
right track they will help spread your
message but when they feel isolated
alone have no confidence they're not
going to do it just like your business
if you feel empowered and confident and
that people are supporting you you're
going to take action but if you feel
beaten down you're in this alone you're
crazy the people you know you won't have
that support you won't feel confident to
keep going you'll give up so create a
home for your crazy customers make them
feel like they're part of something
powerful and they'll help spread the
message for you believe if you like this
video please give it a thumbs up below
it always makes me want to do more and
let me know you think leave a comment
underneath you have a question leave it
below make a video response thank you so
much and I'll see you soon
you